dude I finally saw a racer head and when
I found out that his baby was born his
daughter was born with like web Toes
that they got fixed and I saw the movie
I was like that guy is like a douche
yeah
I can't imagine being his daughter and
saying that like he wanted to kill me
because I was deformed that I brought
like that sort of
well now you're a dad you understand
like toes web toes and children love
children
Bill Burr is with us the last man left
in L.A you're you're you've done it
you're here and you're sticking it out
oh there's plenty of guys out there no I
know I'm kidding but you know how
there's you know they try to depict this
place yeah that is just a you know a
bunch of liberals yeah you know swimming
around an infinity pool and right
talking about gender neutral bathrooms
it's so funny it's the same way the
people out here talk about the red
States oh they're out there you know
[ __ ] their sister
like you guys all need to do the road
yeah and intermingle and everybody can
just relax yeah it's uh stereotypes
exist for a reason but it's these lack
of travel right that's right these
places are big
that's the other thing I think people
don't realize how big Los Angeles is so
yeah they don't realize when you go over
the Hollywood Hills it's Trump land
that's right it becomes real concern I'm
not saying they're into Trump order I'm
not trying to start that [ __ ] I'm just
saying they're conservatives that's like
you go down Magnolia there's like 12 gun
shops down there uh Halloween costumes
sort of a strange Street yeah I did the
San Jose Improv and the drive from here
to up to San Jose Northern California
takes you through all these farms and
they're all just like there's there's
like let's kill Newsom signs and Trump
2024 like it's red and then you get to
San Jose and San Fran it gets blue again
yeah but these are California just came
in the fourth largest economy in the
world U.S China Japan California just
beat Germany oh is that right yeah about
time yeah just be just finally finally I
love that I so don't pay attention to
Paul said I don't even know who Newsome
is the governor I know one name is Gavin
Gavin Newsom yeah he's the governor well
you're busy is he that I'm not busy I
don't pay attention is that is that
cruise guy running against him or is he
mayor
um and he's running against that lady
Karen bass and um uh and uh Rick Caruso
are running for what I love is Karen is
a republican right she's a Democrat
she's a Democrat and this guy was a
republican now he says of two days ago
I've came yeah he was a very he's a
right-wing guy but now he's kind of
running as a Democrat and they're in a
dead he's the old billionaire the old
billionaire guy the old billionaire
going to become a politician and uh help
out the little guy yes he bought the
grow he owns The Grove he developed the
growth
you know that yeah that soulless Place
yeah I like how you go in there yeah how
it sucks your soul out but they're
playing this music like you just you
know yeah you know luck be a lady
tonight yeah yeah you feel successful
when you're there yeah it's a hellscape
and it's you know it's a Cheesecake
Factory and then a bunch of stores and
there's a trolley yeah it takes you
around so he's gonna I apparently do
that for the home I don't know what he's
gonna do but he's gonna solve
homelessness with I think he's gonna put
him in his buildings yeah that he's
gonna make and then there's gonna be
like a 18-month period and he's gonna
kick them all out and then he's gonna
have the building yeah I think that's
how you make a billion dollars you just
know how it works I respect the guy yeah
that he knows you know what we're gonna
do right take all those dirty
[ __ ] yeah stick them in this
shiny [ __ ] everyone's gonna be
like that's awesome
then I leave office I kick all the dirty
[ __ ] out I got this shiny thing
that I'm gonna I'm gonna make the less
lesser dirty people pay for it yeah I
mean that's middle class it's very
possibly what he's gonna do or yeah or
he's a billionaire with a heart of gold
that's also possible the Julia Roberts
maybe he's just a good guy really yeah
maybe Richard Gere picked him up and
took him out on a date yeah and now I'm
a new tuxedo yeah maybe he's a good guy
I mean his son's a DJ so he's kind of
connected
he's connected to losers and regular
people
um you know perhaps he's you know he
that's the big issue everybody at this
point is either a DJ or an influencer
yeah it's it's some there's like six
degrees of separation you even know a DJ
yes or an influencer or you are one your
life you've seen everything changed so
much from when you started you're a
podcaster yeah or a podcaster you've
seen it change so much is it better now
like just life in general is life in
general better now than it was when you
were growing up or do you feel like
it was it had was better than overall
it no it it's a that's a sliding scale
it's all like aspects of it right we're
better I think it was better that you
weren't staring at screens all the time
I think it's a better time now for
artists I think it's a better time now
for uh people who aren't white to be
able to express what's really happening
to them right uh uh I probably your
worst time now for people in hate groups
where they can kind of be like hey man I
didn't know you hated the same [ __ ] I
did you're up in Seattle right Sleepless
in Seattle that's the clan like you kind
of get that [ __ ] going on uh it's I
think it's just like but you know
obviously the environment we've kind of
pushed it to the Limit here it feels
like it's at the breaking point yeah I
feel bad for young people now that
they're kind of down to two seasons it's
either summer or winter it kind of seems
in a lot of places so and I think people
are ignorant too where they're looking
out at La and out here being like yeah
good luck like dude like that's not
gonna slowly come your yeah it's coming
it's coming yeah and when yeah if we
keep going this route because like I I
was looking back he saw you look at the
trees they got the Lush land and the
lakes and stuff and it's just like if it
keeps getting hotter all of those trees
are gonna dry out and then you might
you're just sitting around like a bunch
of old newspapers so yeah I think the
new thing is going to be uh it's not
going to be to solve it it's going to be
the fireproof house
where you can fire proof house with the
infinity pool inside I like that so as
you sit there and you watch people with
less money than you burning to death
right as you're tweeting my heart breaks
for people with less money than me you
stay in there yeah and once they're all
gone then you just sort of absorb yeah
and I think we're going to go back to
those massive ranches that guy like you
know it's like how that one guy owned
Griffith Park like he gave that to La
like one guy had all of that I think
we're gonna go back to that once people
just sort of get you know burned out or
washed away by the Sea it's very
possible what's weird about La is we do
have a lot of homelessness but all of
our hit shows are about real estate like
every show on Netflix like selling
Sunset and you know buying things they
just start dressing like absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're hookers hookers
yeah no no but I watched one of that
Orange County one this woman was selling
a house she's got these beautiful tits
probably not real right dude everything
but our areola yeah her tits were out
and then it plunged all the way down
here and I'm just thinking like if a guy
shows up with his wife right
like that's a really weird
thing where it says hey what'd you think
of that how it looked great
tell me two details of that house right
and none of them know like none of these
if you ask them what the taxes on the
house are they have no idea like they
don't know any real estate questions
they're just hot and I'm sure they know
but what I'm saying is they don't seem
to know that much
I would those are the kinds of women you
want to [ __ ] it as a guy if you're
successful yeah you want to stay away
from yeah because they will they will
they will take your life they'll eat you
yes yeah they'll eat you and then play
the victim and can't and cancel you
yeah well I mean they're they're well
yeah like look at like when I was a kid
that right there that was a movie star
right she was a movie star now she sells
houses she's selling a [ __ ] one level
ranch with an open floor plan yeah
how do you how do you not buy the house
the second you walk in there well and I
think a lot of them are are trading on
the fact that they'll meet Rich guys and
then perhaps you know they might marry
those guys
no you know what I think it is I think
it is that you never used to sell houses
on TV right and then what happened was
probably all the ugly people got shamed
out of that business right and then all
of a sudden they would just because back
in the day stewardesses were hot right I
think all the hot stewardesses are now
selling yeah because houses they are not
hot anymore they're not they look like
me no flight attendants look like
they're that's not true I've seen some
some of them are pretty but some of them
are weather no if you get on if you're
if you're on a uh uh a a mainstream
Airline flying across the country that's
seniority so there's going to be some
miles on that one right yeah if you take
a puddle jumper yes instead of playing
Denver you're doing Colorado Springs
right maybe Grand Junction right
that's where you get somebody who's is
cute yeah yeah yeah but at that point
but at that point I'm 54 so I can't look
at her anyways they're awesome a creep
New York to LA or LA to New York which
is what I do a lot is a lot of it's a
lot of older women yeah who have had it
they've had it they've had it I've had
it yeah they've had it yeah they're like
put the strap and they go the seat belt
they go and the shoulder strap like as
soon as I wear open they like that comic
that stop writing jokes and he hates his
act right they just got to keep doing it
keep rolling through but what's
interesting about uh what you said about
the fireproof houses that is probably
going to be kind of a reality
as stuff gets worse nobody's gonna the
sad thing is none of the politicians are
in a position to turn on corporations
right because they're they're all
grossly underpaid politicians and they
do it because they're supposed to be
public service but what you're really
doing is it's so the rich people can
have them in their pockets they they
need them that's why
um you know the stuff that like those
24-hour news networks go after it's
never you know they're not going to go
after like the big guys that feed them
they go after you know stand-up
comedians telling jokes and uh you know
so yeah some guys yeah some guy slap
somebody at a mall what is this what is
happening to the fabric of America and
they just kind of uh
they don't go after like Blackstone that
buys all these houses now and pushes the
values of them up and they've locked
people out of renting like they don't go
after companies like that like over the
pharmaceutical companies yeah they're
just selling liquor you know yeah
synthetic heroin that's all yeah killing
hundreds of thousands of people
devastating families there's one that's
not a big deal but did you see what Tim
Dillon said right right San Jose and
that's like uh
what do they call that when you're
you're like that joke I did uh at Red
Rocks when I saw a bunch of [ __ ]
liberal idiots out here going after dead
John Wayne right I'm speaking to dead
power like they were doing their thing
as a white person that day it was just
so [ __ ] stupid right settling scores
with dead people yeah putting them
historically introspective the a live
white guy that still has power that I
need to get my movie made I won't speak
to him right right but I'll try to
change the name of an airport yeah
you're welcome black people does that
ever do you think what changes that
where corporations run everything they
just seem to run everything and they
will forever
uh yeah yeah I think the the only game
to play now is yourself as far as just
trying to be a nice person right an
individual you know I was talking to you
earlier I said hey I ran into this
squirrely little guy uh I mean watch
yourself if you're around you know just
[ __ ] like that yeah that's that's kind
of like um
you know I've been doing this bit in my
ACT about talking about what your job as
an older person is to help out younger
people right and whatever mistakes you
made you know you're selling this is
what I did this didn't work and this is
what worked and that's what you're
supposed to be doing and
um I I think that
you know if you're a comic that's doing
well you part of that of doing well is
helping out comics
that are are struggling
it just is and I think
you know if you're a white person you
should shut up and listen to people of
other races saying what their
experiences right rather than trying to
be like you know well actually you know
Africans actually sold black people into
slavery so uh slavery was like just
doing that
that [ __ ] is that's not helpful well
then you just you it's like you're
playing teams
you know what I mean like I'm a Patriots
fan I can sit here and tell you that Mac
Jones kicked that guy in the balls
deliberately when he did that slide
[ __ ] dirty play right it was a helmet
to foot [ __ ]
[ __ ] right there okay but what people do
is you can get so into whatever the [ __ ]
you are whatever the hell you're rooting
for like Astro fans you know where you
know when was the last time you saw an
astral fan have you ever heard an astro
fans say we wow we are the first team
that literally fixed the World Series
since the 1919 White Sox they don't
right up until that moment they were
like oh the [ __ ] Patriots [ __ ]
cheaters deflate game
I went out this movie I did there was an
actor on it who was an astro fan I asked
him about it he goes everybody does it
every big smile on his face everybody
does it everybody everybody does that
yeah no everyone does not do that
everybody knows what pitch is coming I
don't think they did that
so that's been kind of bugging me not
that they did it because I'm a Red Sox
fan and we had 18200 there's not enough
people angry at them they're not getting
[ __ ] about it and what I've kind of
realized is if you do some Ticky tack
[ __ ] that story will last forever
pumping crowd noise in you know they
weigh your football and that's a [ __ ]
hair lighter yeah that'll last for
something big that [ __ ] with
everybody's money right see I swept
under the rug yeah it's they
investigated there's a quick judgment
this guy that guy and that guy that's it
all right and then nobody like I watched
that Yankees series against him they
didn't [ __ ] bring it up once and I
was you know
that's because I haven't given them [ __ ]
until now I'm like all right I don't
give a [ __ ] that you did it yeah well
you should get your your Just Desserts
of [ __ ] for it yeah well some something
stick and some things don't I think
that's what I was trying to say too yeah
that's it
you really just summed it up if you were
going to commercial that would have been
perfect Kevin Spacey just skied off he
may be back you know he just got a he
got a um
he's found not responsible or not liable
in a New York or a jury let him so he
might come back not liable for what he's
some some 14 year old claimed he sat on
him or something he grabbed on me some
sexual assault type of thing that they
just figured out they were like we just
they said we're not gonna We're Not
Gonna We're Not Gonna today is your day
you get to leave the court and we're
gonna say you're not this is going to be
the funniest charge I've ever heard in
my life but he sat on a 14 year old
please tell me he had clothes on yeah
you know he had clothes on allegedly
it's it's allegedly he was uh Kevin you
allegedly sat on a 14 year old how do
you please he said he picked him up like
a groom does a bride and uh put him on a
bed and lay down on him and uh then the
guy was like whoa he's at a party and
they just did a court case and they let
him go they said you're okay
there's no way that's one of those
things where you're like you know he did
it you know it was creepy there's just
no way to prove it it's like the world
prove it yeah what I have learned is the
world it that that system it really
protects
uh you know it just it's so it's it's
weird it's so [ __ ] hard to prove
you know how do you prove that you can't
you just got to go on the stand and get
teary-eyed and say that guy did it and
then he's gonna get up and or somebody's
gonna get up and go no he didn't and
then the jury's got to make up their
minds
I know and then you can't punch him in
the face because then you get busted for
assault
yeah it just it doesn't make any sense
so all I can say is I hope he is
innocent I hope he didn't do that I hope
he I hope he didn't sit on a 14. I hope
he did not I hope he didn't do that
sorry I he I if I had to if I was a
guest if I had a gun in my head
we were so far apart at the beginning of
this podcast and we we've found a middle
ground we both hope some things stick
some things don't
some people some people come back with
the me too things some people do some
people don't some people see know what a
chair is some people confuse it with a
14 year old
[Laughter]
they're wearing muted colors I mean it's
it's an easy mistake to make who knows
the Mind does crazy things yeah some
politicians get away with a lot of stuff
Nancy Pelosi gets away with some stuff
the trading and stuff and you know she's
and some people don't get away with
anything I don't have no idea what
you're talking about yeah I mean well
she does her and her husband they're
really rich she's really rich they're
all rich yeah they all do unbelievably
well in the private sector that's right
what it's amazing everything they touch
turns the [ __ ] gold every Senator
makes like 150 Grand they're all worth
like 20 million dollars every president
does one or two terms making 200 Grand a
year and then buys a 20 million dollar
house on Martha's Vineyard
nobody says [ __ ] nobody says [ __ ] but if
you do a [ __ ] uh I don't know some
rapey joke yeah all of a sudden you're
wrong oh Jesus what are you doing to the
fabric yeah yeah huh what are you doing
to the quilt it's uh well you're you're
in one of the most successful Comics
ever do you ever get an ass too how
about that well that's I think that's
statistically true do you ever get asked
to to perform for these types of people
like I know that certain guys do private
gigs or corporate gigs we're like you're
around no I don't and I wouldn't either
right because then it's like I will
because
that was a time where I would have but
I'm in a position now where I don't need
to when I wouldn't because I don't want
to have a relationship with any of those
people my job is to make fun of those
people that's right you have to go there
and play grab ass with them yeah and
then the next time they do something
[ __ ] up I feel like I can't joke about
it because uh you know uh you know I
went to the the black tie event yeah
yeah
those crowds aren't good they suck the
shows aren't fun for the most part
I think the correspondence dinner was a
cool thing to do until they televised it
and then every side just like loses
their [ __ ] mind yeah
um you know whoever the comic is that
goes up there and and you know
trashes whatever colored tie the
person's [ __ ] wearing it's really uh
would you do the correspondence Dave I
wonder if I don't think they have you
because they'd be like terrified they
wouldn't be terrified they just well
they wouldn't want you know those guys
like have dead bodies on them yeah they
think they couldn't [ __ ] handle me
with one nerd with a drone yeah I fly by
my bedroom window they are not terrified
of anybody yeah they just don't have
they just want to have a nice night they
just want to have a fun time yeah a fun
time that's yeah they just look at me
like the jerk off I am yeah well I mean
whatever file cabinet The Jerk up but
they believe me dude they are not
they are not of they they do they run
they run [ __ ] yeah or at least work for
the people that are running running they
certainly work for the people that are
running it definitely I do the improvs
yeah
they're good I don't think they're a
threat they're good rooms a few decades
ago private citizens used to be largely
that private what's changed the internet
think about everything you've browsed
searched watched tweeted now imagine all
that data being crawled through
collected and aggregated by Third
parties in a permanent public record
your record
having your private life exposed for
others to see what was once something
only celebrities worry about but now
everybody's gonna have that issue so to
keep my data private we use expressvpn
everybody does uh there's hundreds of
data Brokers out there they're all
trying to steal your information and
sell it so go to expressvpn it's so
important to have they scramble your IP
address nobody knows it's you it's hard
to sell your data so if if you like me
you believe your data is your business
go to
expressvpn.com Kim Dillon get three
months for free that's crazy e x p r e s
s vpn.com Tim Dylan if you use the promo
code you get three months for free so
you do not have people stealing and
harvesting your data selling it to third
parties you retain your privacy and you
get three months for free
expressvpn.com Jim Dylan I use it
everybody I know uses it they're all
happier they're all more private go do
it do you think that um when climate uh
do you think in the next 30 Years 50
years do you think there's a timeline on
it where it gets hairy like because it
gets hairy eye yes a non-scientist I
have no idea You observe things you're
out there in the world yeah what's the
deal with global war I say 30 years
that's what I've been saying
just based on my calculations driving
around rolling the windows down well
what the
thing that happened to me when I had a
kid is I I became more positive about
the future because that's the only thing
you can do because if you start thinking
that you know in 30 years we're [ __ ]
we're summoned me I'm 54. now I'll be
84. uh you know like if I get 84 years
before I burst into flights yeah that's
whatever whatever's gonna happen or get
washed out from some [ __ ] Rogue Wave
um yeah that's fine but for my kids that
isn't fun so I I have to believe that
um
even these lunatics these [ __ ]
[ __ ] lunatics yeah that run like the
people that run corporations are [ __ ]
lunatics these people just even people
who are involved and with this the lot
designed obsolescence where everything
you just have to [ __ ] throw out I was
talking the other day how like you'd buy
a [ __ ] TV when I was a kid you had it
for like 25 years yeah and if they the
tube would break the guide come over put
a new tube in it
it was like a showpiece and now it's
like I don't know how many flat screen
TVs all of a sudden it's like yeah this
thing isn't you know it's not up to par
they should make them where you can just
sort of switch something out of the back
or we could all at some point just say
hey you know what I think the picture's
clear enough right why don't we just
stop I don't need to see every [ __ ]
poor yeah on the inside the guy's
[ __ ] you know inner ear when I'm
watching him tell me you know if [ __ ]
the Trailblazers won well it's a lot of
it's like the phone it's like a new
phone every year new phone charger every
year kids that grow up the charger
doesn't the new charger doesn't work but
the old charger you just gotta throw it
all out and places like that from what I
heard don't want to get sued they they
would rather pay the fine the fine is so
much less than the money that they make
and they got to start making the fine
more but they don't make any [ __ ]
money and you go goddamn well those
corporations they give money they give
money and they give money to these
politicians yeah it's all just shut them
the [ __ ] up so they can keep dude the
fact that you can't drink water are out
of a river anywhere
yeah in my lifetime that that happened
you gotta drink bottled water and all
that that basically these corporations
poisoned
the water supply dude if I do that you
do that that's a terrorist act you're
you're in jail for the rest of your life
these [ __ ] guys you think ding ding
ding ding they [ __ ] yeah the money's
out there and then they just create like
a new market why are we good you know
you got the space behind you we're going
we're going too deep here well you know
what it is it's the influence of the
background not even noon yet
you're in the desert this is what we got
to change the studio during the pandemic
it made a lot of sense to kind of be in
this desert landscape but now that
things are back we want to lighten it up
a bit because it's a dark it's a Vortex
what you should have is maybe this it's
dawn like the sun maybe we're just
starting to come we'll do that perhaps
Civil Twilight yeah like because this
sucks you in you start you want to start
yelling about the poison Rivers that's
the backdrop it is you want to start but
I just you're right I just wish people
would just
like not be [ __ ] to each other well
you said made a lot of sense when they
do like you know I saw this thing the
other day just randomly on uh whatever
the [ __ ] site I was on or it was a
text threat between me and my friends
look at this new weapon that that
[ __ ]
you know China has it was a [ __ ]
robot dog with like a machine gun yeah
he just sends me this
so I'm going you know I was just going
I'm sure we already have one of those
and pretty soon it'll fly over a
football game and we're all gonna cheer
yeah like I'm not gonna sit here
and and get like worked up
about China and all that like I know
that they have sociopaths over there too
right as we have them over here so I
just sort of look at it that way you
know what I mean it's kind of like uh
how we looked at Red Sox and Yankees
it's like you spend way too much money
we spend too way too much money you guys
did a bunch of roids we did a bunch of
roids right I'm not gonna sit here and
act like yeah their dirt is dirtier than
our dirt no it's not so I kind of look
at that
um I I mean also I am really overly
simplifying like world events because
but it's a good outlook when you said
people just focus on yourself and not
being a piece of [ __ ]
yeah and helping people out helping
people out rather than blaming them for
this situation or just hey pull your
[ __ ] yeah but I mean I'm not saying
that telling somebody to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps like I I like
really believe in a lot of conservative
stuff and a lot of liberal stuff and it
what it is is there's nothing wrong with
either Outlook it's the application of
it it's when you do it
is it time to give somebody a hug and
there's a time to go get your gun yes
right yes so you shouldn't always get
your gun then your oppressive [ __ ]
sometimes if you're always walking
around hugging people you can end up in
the trunk of somebody's car right and
now we have this weird thing where we
hug people with a gun like we have this
very weird middle of the road
strange thing where like nothing feels
genuine on either side I think that's my
biggest takeaway is that like things
don't feel authentic things feel very
engineered and managed and I hope we get
to a point when people are more
just you know a little more natural I
feel like things are well that's because
I I think because so many people are on
TV now yeah even like you have your own
Instagram page yeah all of that type of
stuff that's why like I think overall
like the level of fashion
cooking and and just looks like how
people look I mean I watch I love old
movies and [ __ ] and I look at some guys
and I'm like that guy's [ __ ] 31 he
looks like he's 56. like that's what a
56 year old looks like that lives in a
city yeah you know like some of the
people back then I mean Brian Denny he
used to exist yeah you know what I mean
like Brian Denny was kind of a sex
symbol to certain types of women my
nanny my grandmother from Ireland loved
Brian Denny
no like guys like George Kennedy George
Kennedy always looked like he was 63.
his whole career I don't know if you
know who that guy is but he was in those
uh uh uh George Kennedy he was in Cool
Hand Luke yeah he he actually was played
up is it Frank drebin in the Naked Gun
yeah he was yeah I know exactly who it
is
look at that guy's face yeah
always looked old
even like the yeah let's try to get when
he's sort of young
look look up young George Kennedy
and still and you can see to the guy
that guy is like you would not want to
fight that guy no on any level there you
go look at that one
still could pass for his mid-40s there
yeah good looking it was distinguished
yeah get mad at them eggs
um
use a distinguished guy yeah there
wasn't there was there was no Timothy's
and God bless him people smoked and they
drank they ate [ __ ]
like they didn't know how to put put the
diet together or whatever they that they
were eating
um you know nowadays I mean
I just met a guy who was an agent and
all he drinks is like these [ __ ]
smoothie shakes
and this guy dude I've never said this
about another man he was radiant yeah
like I thought I thought about him for
like three days his hair was like like a
[ __ ] like a you know like those
Collies yeah Westminster that's a border
yeah you would brush he had like you
know when the chicks do that thing in
the shampoo commercial from behind and
it comes down and there's like that
rainbow like that was silence guys there
you think a guy like that that's so
radiant eventually just hits a point one
day where he just is it like Michael
Douglas and falling down where he just
at a stoplight one day just gets out of
his car and just starts going nuts like
people that are what would be him going
out he goes into a Jack In The Box yeah
I guess yeah well that's what I mean
French fries
I mean he loses it and has a mozzarella
stick but I mean I love how you compare
just drinking smoothies yeah to a guy
going on a shooting spree
I just mean that like it seems like it's
got an expiration date that's all like
uh smoothies
oh no I think it was beyond that like I
think he was one of the most people that
went to scientists and had his DNA it
was [ __ ] impressive yeah
um so is that important but that or is a
little bit of it like
I don't know I know I understand that it
is impressive to keep yourself look
there's obviously a level of ridiculous
vanity to it but you just know that
that's possible yeah you know it was
very like Michael Jordan right like a
lot of those moves that kids did for the
last 20 years because Jordan showed you
that you could do it right uh and that's
the genius of the first guy the Jimi
Hendrix the Eddie Van Halen's you know
the guys like that so like as far as
like being like in shape
you know yes he that guy did not make me
afraid of of being 60 at some point easy
well yeah he's inspired well people are
getting older and older and looking
better and better and maybe you know I
mean people are
people are thriving
well into old age yeah it's weird it's
it's interesting well considering they
turned our food into poison I don't know
how we're doing it well because we're
turning it we're turning it back into
non-poison but it just takes money
because you can really eat the best of
the best all right now what do you think
you need to make a year yeah to eat the
way a [ __ ] hobo ate in the 1920s
ah where everything was [ __ ] organic
yeah you have to make a lot you have to
make a lot what do you think what do you
think the number is
two hundred thousand a year after taxes
in this state easily
to eat wild salmon to eat organic
everything yeah
you don't think you want to agree I
don't I seem low food is [ __ ] it
might be it's super expensive and then
it goes bad really quick immediately
like the fruits and vegetables yeah okay
like the way you eat the fries and the
McDonald's on the way home you gotta be
eating the fruits well you let your
children have fast food every now and
then like because my parents let us have
it all the time which was the wrong way
to do it in the 90s they would just I
mean McDonald it was like Hey Party Time
Wendy's all that stuff very bad oh
Wendy's then Wendy's was like going out
getting steak when I was like this was
amazing do you remember when they used
to have the newspaper the newspaper
tabletop the old-timey newspapers and a
salad bar yeah that nobody went to
nobody went to it but it had pudding
Wendy's was uh the top of the line fast
food when I was growing up it was the
only one that actually looked like it
used real meat yeah and they had the
square Burger which was weird it was
weird but it was the way for them to say
this is meat
was the way for them to say it's
different we're different
that was it yeah yeah it was a weird
brand where they were like no this is an
actual thing yeah to answer your
question I don't take them out for fast
food but
uh their relatives do okay you know
grandmas and uncles and stuff like that
someone's got to be cool but yes
exactly right and I'm not supposed to be
cool because I'm your dad so I'm your
day to day right so if I'm your day to
day for the most part you're not going
to have it and then you're going to be
psyched when your uncle comes over your
nana whatever and they're going to take
you to McDonald's or Jack in the Box or
whatever it's like you know right like
when that's kind of how like uh
you know like we weren't allowed to
drink soda
when I was growing up but if we went out
to get pizza you could order it and when
we went out to but we used to go out to
McDonald's all the time like that was
like going out to eat that was another
thing too like I think when you talk
about something that was better back
then
I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to make this point by saying
McDonald's was our idea of fine dining
but like
um the fact that you just didn't know
right all of this stuff you were happy
with simpler things like I was like how
mainstream high-end fashion is now
where I had never heard
of Louis Vuitton East Saint Laurent all
this time right now you know I got a
wife so now I know all of that [ __ ] but
like
those stores back in the day were on
Rodeo Drive and on Fifth Avenue New York
and I think that you maybe in Chicago on
what is that New York Michigan Avenue
yeah that was it yeah like women like
dreamed of someday going to these stores
and seeing this this fashion that they
saw like uh I don't know who like uh
breakfast at Tiffany lady there right
and now I remember when I was I was
doing some
you know some Road gig through the uh
some road trip through the South and we
were like in like Mobile Alabama or
something someplace it was really
exciting because I watched that Ken
Burns the war and they made all those
battleships down there so it was really
a historic place to go to and I went to
the local mall and there was a Louis
Vuitton yeah I don't know if it was
Mobile Alabama but it was somewhere and
it was like uh yeah it's
um
and I've noticed that too the amount of
people like
going into coach on a plane I don't know
if they're real bags enough you see this
high-end bag and I'm just thinking to
myself when I sat back there dude I just
had like a [ __ ] gym bag right
um and it's just this is that kind of
thing of like just knowing
too much and uh and also I think a lot
of people that are in the public eye
they kind of sell having that stuff
making you happy and [ __ ] like that and
none of it does no there's a couple
things you get yourself a nice watch
yeah you know what I mean a nice Koozie
said to me about my car uh which is uh
Bentley you said to me good nobody
believes that's your car everybody
thinks you're driving and you know what
I realized you're correct everybody
thinks I'm a driver I think you're
parking it they think I'm parking it
because they're all nice to me like if I
go to Vons a grocery store and in the
Bentley nobody gives me a look like oh
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] they're like
oh he's running an errand for somebody
but that was the personal assistant
I can't believe his boss lets him drive
the car but that was a dumb thing I got
where it's like I wanted to get a dumb
thing you know sometimes you got to get
a dumb thing and it's a nice car but
sometimes you have to get a dumb thing
you know we would tease in Versi yeah
when he did your podcast yeah uh was
when you took him out in a white Bentley
yeah and took him out for Italian food
yeah he's grooming you yeah yeah
it's like yeah you can't you wouldn't
you can't take it exactly you take out
an Italian yeah you know and a high-end
car with white then [ __ ] you know you
give them sneakers that's it that's what
you'd have to do it's over well yeah
that is the keys to that say yeah all
right but are you but you're a y like
you'll appreciate a nice watch so it's
like everybody's got something that oh
you know what I like I like uh I like
people that are really good at what they
do provided it doesn't hurt anybody else
so I am into like
uh cars trucks motorcycles
uh uh I like watching people hunt I like
I'm right now like I've been watching
people like like power wash driveways
and walkways it's just there's something
so satisfying yeah about it maybe
because I'm a homeowner or whatever and
I'm like I gotta [ __ ] get somebody to
power wash my driveway that'd be great
and then there's all these laws about
you know using the water out here I love
the box of Awesome from bespoke Posts
because what you do is you take a quiz
and it doesn't have to be for you it's
great to give as a gift or it can be for
you this quiz establishes things you're
into are you an Outdoorsman do you like
cooking what whatever then you get a box
every single month ninety percent of it
of the things in the Box come from
American small businesses okay these
boxes contain all kinds of cool things
that are related to your general area of
Interest okay could be cocktail kits
could be things for traveling things for
camping things for doing all kinds of
stuff woodworking whatever you happen to
be into they will have put these little
boxes together it's great to give to
somebody who's moving to a new city or
who's going to college because it's a
it's a 12-month gift you can stop and
start at any time each box is valued at
around 70 dollars but you only pay a
fraction of that price plus with each
box of awesome you're supporting small
business 90 like I said of everything
comes from a small company so if you
want to do this which is a great [ __ ]
gift get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code Tim Dillon at checkout
that's box of awesome.com and to the
code Tim Dillon at checkout it's one of
my favorite things that we sell on the
show I who signed up for this I got a
box and it had like pancake flour a
loaded gun it had the tail of a cat it
had some Voodoo [ __ ] to curse myself or
others uh it was really really cool one
box had a vial of blood and just kind of
a ransom note in it that was taking you
know the letters from the different
magazines was cut out you you know one
box just you know had a picture of
Richard Nixon uh and some literature
um I I love it it's just great so go to
box of awesome.com Metro promo code Tim
Dillon box of awesome.com promo code Tim
d-i-l-l-o-n ship station is what
everybody uses to ship products they
work with all the different shippers and
carriers and it allows you to focus on
whatever the most important part of your
business is originating new ideas
working on the you know marketing of
those ideas ship station just allows you
to basically run your back office it
keeps track of your orders okay it works
with everybody Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify making it easier to
manage all your shipping needs from one
simple dashboard you maximize your sales
with minimal effort save time with
Consolidated order management automated
shipping up updates for your customers
easily compare carriers rates and
delivery times to get the most out of
every single Cent
um
I love shipstation it's so easy
um it's really really great I you never
worry about where this stuff's going if
it got there you know everything you
don't have to really be uh anxious
go to shipstation.com today and sign up
with promo code Tim Dylan you get a free
60-day trial start today and get set up
before the biggest shipping season of
the year is this going to be crazy if
you're making little like
trinkets in your house maybe you're
selling like making little ornaments out
of acorns and people could put on the
Christmas tree
maybe you're doing uh some type of craft
that you're selling to people
on the internet and people like it and
they're going wow but you go I gotta
focus on making the acorn you know look
like Santa Claus then you yeah you can't
worry about the shipping
you see if your focused if you're
sitting home and maybe you've had a
couple of drinks you got half a bag on
and you're making a putting googly eyes
on an acorn making them look like Santa
Claus because you don't want to live
anymore and you're trying to make a
little money the last thing you need is
to worry about shipping so you go to
shipstation.com sign up with promo code
Tim Dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n for a free 60-day
trial start today and get set up before
everything goes crazy for the holidays
that's two months free visit
shipstation.com Click the microphone at
the top type in code Tim Dylan but uh
like you know chefs or something like
that and so I'll get into something and
then what I always do is I use like the
Dave Attell thing it's like I want to
find the David tell
of pizza makers where other Pizza makers
are going to stand in the back and watch
this guy make a pizza right or or uh
customize a car or build like a
motorcycle or or something like that so
um
yeah I I am
I'm fascinated with all that there's a
kid that Dean Del Rey introduced me to
that uh uh roll Club his name is saying
he's like a you know I met him he's a 24
year old cobbler and literally makes
shoes the old school way like buying it
you go down there he traces your foot on
a piece of paper you come back two three
weeks later and you just have this shoe
that just fits you like a glove it's
crazy yeah so I I am like that those are
the types of people I like yeah finding
people that do something really well
yeah and like because they have a
passion for it and then they somehow
figured out you know how to make money
off of it yeah so they can keep doing it
I guess yeah I mean those are the things
that if you're lucky enough to to meet
those people those are the things that
leave a mark on you you know when you go
to a restaurant and somebody's like
really good and really even a waiter who
really cares oh yeah real rear waiter no
like a Russo and Frank yeah they're
[ __ ] unbelievable they're
unbelievable yeah like Smith wolinsky's
in New York City or Dale's guy is
fantastic they know your name they know
what drink you like like that's the okay
there's some [ __ ] from back in the day
that needs to come back but not you
don't do it ironically and you don't do
it in a hipster way that's the hardest
[ __ ] thing right is when you go in
there and they know who you are they
know what you drink you come in there
like uh you know I have some friends of
mine you know they got their name up
there on the restaurant the little gold
thing there so they come in they know
the table they like yeah you know they
know the night that they go in there
right and
um
yeah I mean they know his kid's name you
know he never really brings his kid in
there but like they know he has a kid
they know all of that type of stuff and
that's sort of kind of like the
connective tissue where it's like like
this is like solid and this is real I I
think it's kind of a hard
thing
getting back to DJs I find the more
places I go to it's so [ __ ] loud I
went out to go get sushi with my wife
the other night you know my ears are
shot obviously I had to put [ __ ]
earplugs in yeah it's crazy well because
what they're doing is is Everything
feels like a club it's a Vibe yeah and
it's like aren't we supposed to be
creating this Vibe if we're not cool
enough yeah to create a vibe that we
should sit here in the boringness that
is us but instead like like you listen
to it I feel like I'm in the beginning
of a movie like like oh [ __ ] is it gonna
be like a car chase is something gonna
pull out a weapon here like what's gonna
happen it's like oh we're just getting
Sushi well it feels that's where I feel
like everything feels weirdly engineered
where every place you go there's music
there's a Vibe that's being created and
that's you hit it on the head and a lot
of times it was in the parking lot you
heard it in the restaurant you went in
the restroom you couldn't get it there
was just a [ __ ] DJ just [ __ ] right
there and the vibe is off a lot of times
it's the wrong Vibe you're like this is
not what we want a spicy tuna roll we
don't want we don't want Molly and we're
not trying to we're not in a beat yeah
I'm not a rave right yeah well I've got
a Yellow Tail roll
yeah but that's that's that's where
where you see it it's like nothing's
enough anymore no one could just sell
Sushi see what you were talking about is
like the cobbler's just selling shoes
yeah don't walk into his thing and hear
a DJ when you're really really good at
something you just sell the thing when
you're like there's a million sushi
restaurants wherever you are they're all
going okay well we're gonna be the one
with the DJ like they all have to
compensate for the fact that there's a
million other things that people can do
maybe that's what it is yeah I think
back in the day
like there was less well I think scenes
could develop right where you know now
as soon as something develops it's
co-opted immediately as soon as somebody
sniffs out a little bit of money in
something yeah and then people kind of
like rip it off or whatever so but maybe
that's the new scene maybe scenes aren't
small maybe they just got bigger and I'm
too old to realize that I don't know but
like uh can you give me an example of
something that you're talking about that
would was just I would say well like uh
you know star car racing coming out of
the South where it was just these
Moonshiners my car's faster than your
car they start erasing each other that
builds into that people uh skateboarding
out here yeah turns into this Global
thing uh and it took a while for those
things to have rap music in New York
City and all of a sudden that like goes
Global Music was a big thing like there
was like a sounds that you know oh
that's a San Francisco sound that's a
Seattle sound that's a Philly Sound New
York Boston had a scene and everybody
would like and
you know whatever back in the day I mean
it was
the gatekeeper days where they would
just be like all right if they decided I
guess I don't know how it worked this is
the new sound then they would go there
and then that scene would be cool but
like they were able to kind of develop
um I remember reading uh Miles Davis's
autobiography and that was like a like
back then like before like TV and like
even [ __ ] I think radio was just
around
so you just had like everybody was like
like
cauterized these scenes they didn't
intermingle so they would take people
were aware of jazz and swing music but
it became whoever you would whatever
like Eddie you were spinning in and it
would develop like that and then it
would develop and then when they would
get to New York City and that minton's
jazz place I always heard about yeah it
was like you you came with Vanguard yeah
you came up in St Louis I came up in New
Orleans and Chicago and then we went
there and then mixed with New York
people and then it became something else
um but like I could learn
so much from you because you would be so
developed
and and separate and different so I I
think
um is it good for Comics to put out a
lot of stuff all the time I know that
young Comics I love the faith you have
in me with these big [ __ ] questions
you're the guy well you're one of the
guys to ask you know okay well just know
that I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing but go ahead with Comics everybody
puts out a lot of stuff now and back
then you would work on something longer
and you wouldn't put it out like is it
good to put out a lot of stuff like it's
it's I think it's all comes it's an
individual thing right it all depends on
what you're trying to do there's
everybody from I want to be one of the
great comics of all time to I want to
use this to get into TV and movies and
there's nothing wrong with that like I
never had a problem with people that did
stand up for a minute just so they could
launch a TV like it's not mine right
like these people who feel like because
they do stand up that they own stand up
it's like you don't people can do it for
whatever the [ __ ] reason right you got
canceled so now you got to do stand up I
get it I don't give a [ __ ] good luck I
hope you [ __ ] you know whatever but
um I just you know
um
it all depends on what you want to do if
you want to be like a brand
um and God knows there's a lot of money
in that I think uh putting out content
you know a lot
I always compare everything I usually
I'm comparing it eventually to music or
Sports so the bands and musicians that I
like
they seemed to take time and they always
know right when you're sitting there
going like [ __ ] man are they going to
put out another album and then bam then
they're promoting it and they're
everywhere and they do the tour and then
they're just gone
and and then they just like I feel like
live life
I find for like writing jokes I almost I
need to I need to have a lot of like be
living life like this year
you know doing this movie
um and also trying to do a stand-up tour
I found was too much I mean I loved both
of them but to do both of them at the
same time and then try to be a dad and a
husband and all that became
um that was a lot so something had to
suffer and I feel like my ACT has been
moving like a glacier and
um
now that we just locked the movie and
all of a sudden I feel like you know
elephant or Kevin Spacey just got off my
chest right allegedly
um I feel like uh you know I went down
to the store the other night
after having a couple two three days and
not you know put my nose to the
grindstone and my brain just felt like
empty in a good way
and I went up there and I started
riffing and I I had a just the best time
yeah and I got all like this new [ __ ]
out
and you know I did 20 minutes and it
felt like I did like five minutes was
one of those nights and um
you know like I don't know I think it
all depends on how
you know I need that
to still be be doing stand-up at an
acceptable level other people
seem to be able to just seem to me to
just be like tireless like they can just
keep going so
to answer your question I mean I think
that's just an individual yeah thing and
and that's a tremendous amount of wasted
energy as a comedian for you to look at
another comedian and be like what the
[ __ ] they always [ __ ] it's like who
gives a [ __ ] that's what that's what
they want to do young guys got to figure
it out like on their own how they want
to do it yeah and hating on other
comedians is part of being a young comic
that is yes sure I did that in my 20s
then you're 30s Stan hope said the
second best thing about comedy's killing
and the first best thing is sitting in
the back of the room with a bunch of
other Comics going that guy sucks
I think that was the movie you just
wrapped
how long did it take you to shoot uh we
did it in 24 days wow yeah and you did
it all in one location
well we did it out here in La okay so
because everybody involved
um with getting the thing going you know
was married and had kids and that type
of thing so it's just like
you're writing the script where does it
take place you're like it takes place
here right here
are you when does it come out uh I don't
know yet oh that's that's all uh being
decided by the people that decide all
that stuff so um when you lock a movie
it means the editing's over yeah the
editing is over so what we have to do
now is we have a little bit of scoring
that we have to do and we have to color
it and then there's the ADR which is
basically any uh any lines that were
either mumbled said too quickly or it
was a car driving by or a helicopter or
something so that's the last few things
you put in
and then uh then they get a release date
and then you go on the Press tour
and then it comes out and hopefully it
you know
you know when it comes out then you yeah
you do all the
all the shows which are now like
podcasts yeah you know are you happy
with it yes very happy good
yeah yeah
um I was yeah it's it's uh we'll see I
mean we just screened it in Vegas
which you know that's America right
there everybody you can't get more
America yeah it's like everybody from
every state every political background
and people will howling and watching it
so I got I heard that it was first he
said it's amazing like
very insanely funny it's it's funny it's
funny I don't wanna I don't over hype
anything I think if you see it you're
gonna laugh and you're gonna feel like
you got your money's worth our con you
think comedies might come back a little
bit
they've been I think it wasn't
profitable for a lot of Studios to make
them because DVD no they just got caught
up in in in all of this [ __ ] and they
listened to their lawyers and stuff
right and they think that everybody
like people out here and in New York
they live in a bubble like it's not
they're not living in reality and it's
really hard to convey that to them and I
understand that position too because
you know the person who sits behind the
day you know you and I we do something
that bombs that [ __ ] it I got my podcast
I got my road dates whatever they get
fired that's right and they lose their
benefits they could lose their house and
God knows you know
so they're way going to be way more
conservative and they the you know the
the sky is falling is going to land with
them a lot easier so you have to have
empathy
for them so but I just wish that they
would come on the road with us
and see what you know that people uh
are you know they have their own lives
they're too busy to give a [ __ ] yeah
well that's the thing I always said
about
there is hatred in the country for sure
but most people don't have the time most
people aren't invested in hating you
they might misunderstand you or they
might not understand things you believe
but it always seemed weird to me to
think that they were just people that
were just stewing in their hatred of you
some of them might be but I think the
vast majority of people are busy
yeah I would say that but those and
they're also the sad thing is the vast
majority is also too busy to help
because there's no reason there's no
reason why these these uh
hate groups should exist there should be
enough
uh
uh I don't know education and I don't I
don't under I don't understand yeah
that that you know well I think it's a
lot of people that
had a pathway to a life at a certain
point but that's become more I shouldn't
even say I don't understand that because
I grew up semi-sheltered in Boston
and there was a time you know with like
you know somebody told a racist joke or
whatever like I just I mean I I didn't
have a frame of I kind of had a frame
reference but like not enough I was just
a white kid in the suburbs so you would
laugh and there was a time where I
thought saying racist [ __ ] you know was
like you know may just sound tough and I
didn't think I was tough so it was kind
of like that but like
you know my parents had a wide variety
of friends so I always had those
examples in my head like I don't really
believe that or whatever so I think
that's kind of like what people need
yeah and then also I think that people
need to let people grow out of [ __ ]
like because this like this whole
[ __ ] thing of going back in people's
um you know uh
Twitter accounts and all of that [ __ ]
it's just like stupid I mean there's
like [ __ ] three four years ago this
this [ __ ] that I thought or the way I
looked at the world I was just like wow
man I had that 100 wrong and
um
you know I lean left and I gotta say
watching people on the left
go back eight years in somebody's
Twitter and find one comment and be and
Define them by that to ruin them was
really a low point
and I felt that it was and a 100 abuse
of power which was the ironic thing
is that it ends we're fighting Power by
now that we have power now we're gonna
[ __ ] abuse it and I was always
looking I was like dude if you have to
go back eight years to find this guy
being an [ __ ] yeah he's been good for
eight years for seven years he wasn't an
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] amazing because I
I've never done that well Louis said it
there's no more localized stupidity he
said that on we had him on a few weeks
ago people can't be idiots in private
get over it grow up and
that'd be the end of it people because
everything is public now people make
their mistakes online
they make their mistakes what they gotta
stop they gotta try like when somebody
[ __ ] up the first thing you shouldn't
do I don't think the first move is let's
ruin this person yeah it's why wouldn't
you be like all right hey man you
realize when you said that that's makes
you know somebody like this feel this
way or you saying that
does this or whatever and try to like
have a conversation with them because
this whole ramming it down people's
throats it just doesn't uh it it doesn't
work do you know these subjects are so
[ __ ] big dude and then we're not
gonna solve it on this podcast no we did
we just did did we just here's the thing
you just I am an unbelievably flawed
human being so there's only so much that
I can do well I think we're moving into
judge somebody else how how the [ __ ]
could you do what I know I've done in
the past you piece of [ __ ] reminds me of
myself six years ago
I think we're moving into an era of
people that are just trying to Live and
Let Live that's the hope I think we're
over that I think people don't have any
bandwidth for it anymore I think people
are moving on they seem to be like
they've they've learned a lot about
other people's perspectives perhaps
um and they're just trying to say I'm a
human being I love to think that the
silent majority to me the silent
majority is the person who who can watch
a video without commenting on it that's
great those people those are the voters
they should vote
they should follow the people that I
would like running the country they
should be like you can watch a YouTube
video even if it bothered you yeah you
still don't have to leave a con yeah if
you don't have to weigh in then you can
vote and if you've ever written in all
capital letters on YouTube yeah in a
comment you should lose your right to
vote be in jail yeah you should be in
jail what uh are you do you want after
this movie comes out you're gonna go
you're gonna do the whole thing people
are gonna comment and have to put it
back into lowercase yeah they're gonna
have they're they're gonna they're gonna
comment in uppercase now when the movie
comes out you're gonna go on the Press
tour are you at the point now where
you've done a lot of what you wanted to
do you have a ton of specials you've
done the movie it are you getting to a
point where you go I've done a lot and
is is that scary when you go a lot of
the stuff I've wanted to do is done
like you know or is that you put me out
to pasture no I'm just saying we need
work no I'm kidding
um
no I um I like what I'm doing and I just
you know
I remember Keith Richards one time they
said to him like Keith Jesus Christ he
wanted he was like 65
he goes how long are you going to do
this and he was just like what are you
talking about he's I'm a musician yeah
this is what I do I would do this in
front of you know 80 000 or eight people
I would still do it this is literally
what I do and it wasn't [ __ ] because
I remember one time he said something or
he was talking about he still loves like
the smell when he opens a guitar case
just the smell of the guitar yeah and
that person when the interview was like
really goes oh yeah he goes if I could
just crawl in there and close the lid I
would
and then that's just one of those guys
like anytime he comes to town it's like
I have to see that I have to see
somebody
that loves what they do that much do it
like and that because I it if whether I
even realize it I think subconsciously
it affects you to either do what you do
better or to at least try to go find
whatever the joy is
for you your thing that makes you want
to do what he was talking about and if
people if people could connect to that
uh it would certainly be I think a
better world if more people were happy
doing what they do
yeah I don't think I I have a lot of
issues with God and his his [ __ ]
half-assed work that he does on human
beings
are you a Believer yeah he crushed the
mountains the Prairies in the oceans and
then he just slapped human beings
together dude if he was making cars the
amount of recalls yeah
the amount of bailouts he would have to
get on the federal government but he did
a great job with the setting the set is
beautiful like the sushi restaurant yeah
he created the vibe yeah am I a Believer
I mean yeah yeah I mean maybe there's
something but I don't think it cares
yeah I think it's moved on whatever the
[ __ ] it is that's an interesting thing
I've never heard that but that's
actually makes a lot of sense that
whatever it is has moved on
I think it's like a crazy painter yeah
missing an ear and it's just like yeah
it's an earth man it's just [ __ ]
groovy let's put some rings on this one
yeah do it and they'll have DJs and
sushi restaurants yeah he's just in his
bare feet painting where uh where are
you on tour next
are you going back out or are you yeah I
know I have I have 13 dates left
I think I go there's a run I do uh where
I do one of those places is Peoria
Illinois which is amazing because that's
Richard Pryor's uh Hometown that's great
you know only took him [ __ ] forever
to get a statue of him up there
um playing Chicago I know I have Idaho
coming up Colorado Springs I know I have
uh
uh New Orleans I have coming up
uh you know a bunch of
bunch of fun places to go to and I've
been to all of these I literally have a
thing in in my in my phone called places
to go yeah in my notes and I just have
all these restaurants
cigar bars and uh
[ __ ] to do in every town I've ever been
in over the years yeah
so uh that's kind of what I do to stay
out of trouble when I'm out there well
listen I really appreciate you coming on
I know you're busy when does I wish I
could see the movie can you send me
something that I can watch if I don't
share it
yeah okay thank you
because I just love to watch it okay
yeah I appreciate I was you asked me to
do like a little thing in it but I was
in Australia I appreciate oh that's
right yes that's right yeah I appreciate
that you know it had a kind of cop or
whatever role it was probably like a
dock worker but
no yeah okay you actually I think the
roles you give me [ __ ] oh because I was
flipping out in my car okay and then you
sort of watch it like you're not
involved you don't have a dog in the
fight yeah but I just and then I try to
get you to agree with my position and
you do not okay
well we could do that again thank you
for coming on I appreciate it any time I
appreciate it man yeah for sure I
appreciate that you asked me so much
deep [ __ ] that you thought I actually uh
well but you you you said a lot of great
[ __ ]
that's keyword in that is not great it's
[ __ ] but yeah I said a lot of [ __ ] all
we say is [ __ ] but I opened my pie hole
and stuff came out of it's great we get
paid to talk right so you know and talk
in a fun way
speaking of which here's an old guy
thing to help out young people don't you
don't need an agent
to get involved in your podcast money
you hear that Justin sorry yeah like
these I have these kids man that they're
getting this [ __ ] with the agencies are
going to be like oh you know we'll get
you advertising they're just gonna
promise you the [ __ ] Moon so they can
be they can get their foot in the door
that you pay them on the podcast and as
far as I know that'll be like you
booking a series that never ends that's
right and they're gonna even if you
leave that agency they're gonna get your
money forever that's right what gets you
advertising money is you and your talent
and getting [ __ ] listeners don't give
your [ __ ] podcast away don't give
your [ __ ] ownership of your podcast
away there's no reasons for agents to be
sticking their hands in this [ __ ]
that's there you go see that I stand by
Bill Burr all right and we agree thank
you so much good night everybody
there we go